[موسيقى]
دينا رضا اول سيده مصريه تحرر توكيلا في
الشهر العقاري للتبرع باعضائها بعد وفاتها
[موسيقى]
موجوده بره ولقيتها
يعني فكره منطقيه وحلوه وبتدي فرصه للحياه
من لا شيء من لا شيء ممكن كذا بني ادم
يعيش من ولا حاجه هو حقيقي من واحد هينزل
تحت التراب لسبعه ثمانيه بقى عايشين ايه
ده الروعه دي ايه الجمال ده يعني
جون جمال طالب جامعي يحتاج لزراعه كبد وما
زال يحدث الامل في الوصول لمتبرع يتبرع له
بجزء من كبده عله يساعده على الحياه
وممارسه حياته بشكل طبيعي
[موسيقى]
انه هو حلم متاخره جدا
وكل ما الوقت بيمر ده مش في صالحنا خالص
جنب بيجي له غير بوابات كبد وهمم وبيدخل
في حاجه رياكشن مش حلو خالص اتحجزنا في
الرعايه كذا مره
تكشف والدهون المتاعب التي واجهتها وما
زالت تواجهها بسبب عدم وجود متبرع لحالت
نجلها
[موسيقى]
لسه ساعدوني عشان الوزن وقالوا لي هتاخدي
وقت طويل قوي علشان وزنك ينزل والسن 48
سنه فهم السابعدوني خلاص احنا وصلنا
لمرحله اخيره للزرع فلازم همم نتحرك بسرعه
جدا واا الوقت مش في صالحنا لان الولد
حالته متاخره
ولازم الزرع بسرعه
[موسيقى]
دينا ترغب في التبرع باعضائها كامله بعد
الوفاء ولا يهمها راي المعارضين فهي ترى
ان الحياه هبه من الله وان اعضاء الجسد
كذلك
والمتبرع بعد وفاته لا يحتاج لاعضائه
فلماذا لا يتم التبرع بها لمن يحتاجها من
اجل انقاذه وادخال السعاده على اسرته
ممكن الواحد يدي يساعد انه
ثمانيه
نهبلهم حياه جديده حاجه معجزه يعني
[موسيقى]
كل ما بكبر لقيت بكتشف قد ايه الموضوع ده
مهم واساسي وبيرفز بينقذ ناس كثير